allegro andante continuons notre revue
des festivals musicaux de cet été
belfort accueille les eurockéennes les
eurockéennes et la résurrection d'un
groupe anglais the cure éric perrin
didier da vous avez toujours rêvé d'être
une rock star de connaître le frisson de
monter sur scène devant plus de 15000
personnes
et bien ce soir grâce à france 2 soyez
une popstar en restant dans votre
fauteuil vous vous appelez donc damon
albarn et vous êtes le chanteur du
groupe blur qui fait un malheur en
grande bretagne petit détail vous êtes
considéré outre manche comme un sex
symbol et vous venez conquérir le public
français avant la sortie de votre nouvel
album en septembre
voir
et pour vous aider à vous y retrouver
voici une petite leçon pour différencier
une rock-star d'une pop star
nous on n'est pas rock on n'est pas ce
qui veut dire qu'on veut toucher aussi
bien les jeunes que leurs parents et en
plus on n'a pas besoin de porter des
pantalons un peu fou et d'être coiffé
n'importe comment avoir une partie du
public de cette première journée des
européennes
on pouvait se douter qu'un événement se
prépare et cures le retour après trois
ans d'absence
un silence qui n'a pas altéré la passion
assoiffés des fans du chanteur robert
smith chacun essaye de le donner sa
propre image de son propos robert smith
en tête parce qu'il n'ya pas un seul
robert smith là autant que le cloud ya
certes un style que j'aime bien aussi
longs sont inspirés de rim
albert camus de baudelaire de edgar poe
tous
il faudra attendre janvier 96 pour
connaître le nouvel album de cure mais
avec ce concert robert smith a confirmé
qu'il n'a rien perdu de sa voix ni de
son aura comme spider man l'homme
araignée
il a une nouvelle fois attraper sa proie
non